on tuesday eight brooklyn individuals
were charged with multi-million dollar
covid19
relief fraud by obtaining two million
dollars in fraudulent
unemployment benefits and they couldn't
stop
flexing about it i mean look i know it's
tempting to flex on instagram but yeah
if you're gonna commit fraud you have to
stop
ladies and gentlemen i'm doing you a
solid here i gotta tell you guys i'm not
trying to help scammers but
come on we need a we need a better
classic criminal here
this town deserves a better class let's
go to the board here
right uh ladies and gentlemen welcome to
godzilla home of the 10 million dollar
studio
i'm your host and today we're doing the
thing
guys we're going to talk about this
fraud case absolutely
insane of course you can see here that
eight brooklyn individuals were charged
with multi-million dollar coven 19
relief fraud we talked about that
when you actually go into the specifics
it was an unemployment scheme so as many
of you know the cares act
was in uh was passed because they wanted
to give people
extended or um you know expanded
unemployment relief they were able to
submit
false unemployment claims to get money
from a government that was
frankly overwhelmed but for some people
like brian abraham carlos vasquez angel
cabrera
our manny miller all these guys it
became more
than a simple uh way to make a couple
thousand it became a way to make an
entire fortune
by taking other people's information and
submitting
fake unemployment claims on their behalf
the scheme turned into
not only you know just trying to extend
your own unemployment benefits
it became an entire scheme to make
millions so here's how the fraud worked
there are two primary methods for filing
for unemployment in
new york state to make a claim the
claimant was required to provide certain
information including the claimant's
name
date of birth social security number and
employment information if the claim was
accepted the claimant was also required
to establish on a weekly basis
his or her continued eligibility for
unemployment benefits the claimant would
then complete this re-certification by
answering a series of questions again
online or by telephone so this is what
these guys did
according to the doj uh they
submitted claims on other people's
behalf made calls
on other people's behalf and made a ton
of money from it by loading up debit
cards
in other people's name and then they
would go withdraw from atms
but here's where these guys went wrong
they fell for the number one trap of
instagram
which is seems to be trying to flex to
all your friends and family
with the money you're supposedly making
but the problem is the money they were
making
was from fraud and so these people
started to post to social media
carrying stacks of cash fanning out cash
and this is allegedly it is the money
they made from fraudulent unemployment
claims i mean i can't
imagine a more scummy thing to do to
take from honest people who are really
looking for unemployment
and really can't get a job instead
you're flashing cash
standing in front of cars flipping the
bird i guess
look let me say right up front i don't
want to give these people too hard of a
time i mean i looked at their age
they're 18
to like 22 25 and yes that's old enough
to where you should know better but
they're also young enough to where this
could be an honest mistake
that haunts them for the rest of their
life and it is very sad to think that
they may have thrown away their lives
for something so small and i do hope
that they bounce back from this
this is such a disease this clout
chasing i mean number one they probably
did it because they wanted a ton of
money and they thought it was a funny
scheme
but then you're flexing online like
you're a baller
to try to be something you're not and in
order to support that lifestyle you have
to steal
more money i mean like look at this guy
this
bro the problem also is like when a jury
sees this
you're done look just word to the wise
no jury looks fondly on you flashing the
cash of your fraud
i mean it just doesn't work like already
if you commit fraud you're they're
probably going to go with the defense of
like they were kids they didn't know
what they were doing blah blah blah
but then when the prosecutor shows you
just flashing cash
it's a bad look it it is i'm
i'm sorry but it really is and uh you
know i find it unbelievable
that we still are seeing these things go
on i told you guys last time
we had a ppp chronicles episode where
somebody
they they were bragging on facebook
about the new house they bought
with their proceeds what is up with this
epidemic of people
bragging about stolen funds on social
media why do you keep doing it stop it
for your sake it's just not even for me
i laugh at it i think it's funny
but for you guys i mean i'm like come on
what are you doing
you're doing the old like hold the money
to your phone
like ring ring uh you're going to jail
what are you doing what's the money
saying to you right now bud
why i just think it look i really do
think when i'm looking at these ages 18
18
18 19 20 25 i'm it's like this is
tragically young
to be committing this kind of fraud and
um you know it does just make me sad
it makes me sad for him two of the
people armani miller and
johann santos are still remain at large
apparently they haven't caught them yet
but six of these guys have been arrested
and the way they got arrested is pretty
interesting they were caught on security
footage
from uh you know the the atms and so
they were
taking money from the atm and literally
the security cameras just like caught
them
and so this is also part of the evidence
against them
besides the flexing on social media
you've got photographs of them
taking money from the atm of other
people's unemployment
right that they somehow got their
information they applied for
unemployment benefits in their name
and then they're taking that money from
capital one bank
supposedly to use it and uh to flex
guys i hope it was worth it you clout
chased your way to jail for the rest of
you don't do it please
stop okay and i mean
i don't know what people were thinking
that like you could submit a bunch of
false documents and no one would ever
find out
i mean don't forget you had to make
phone calls in these people's name and
so
these people apparently according to the
uh doj's report here carlos vasquez for
example
they used their cell phone numbers as
the third party's
phone number and so when they were
calling weekly about unemployment it
sounds like
that these claims were made like in the
same guy's
voice over and over so imagine you're an
unemployment office going
down your list and like 12 of the guys
sound like the same guy
because it is it's literally the same
guy making the same
answer every time oh yeah still
unemployed terrible you call the next
guy
same guy and you sound a little familiar
no no no no man not uh
it's hard times hard times a ridiculous
scheme made even more ridiculous by the
flexing don't do it
anyways that's basically it that's all i
wanted to say thanks for watching
see you in the next one this ain't what
it seems
nothing but a trick trying to sell me on
a dream but that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee